[Applause]
welcome to another stories from the
stores
I'm here with curator Katie Davin and
today we've got a Dewar flask so this is
a jus a flask for storing heads or
brains in liquid nitrogen for cryogenic
neuro suspension is there a head in
there thankfully there isn't because
that would cause all sorts of headaches
okay but that sounds super sci-fi super
like Futurama it sounds like a mad idea
but the reality is in medicine we use
freezing all the time for cells and
tissues so think about IVF we store
embryos and sperm and cells so it's real
science how does it actually work what
you need to do is preserve the brain and
the head so you need to rapidly cool it
to stop any cellular activity or any
decay happening so you've got to take it
down in three hours to stop any ice
crystals forming and then there's a
longer two-week process of taking it
down to minus 196 Celsius and then these
body parts are preserved for the future
until they could be brought back to life
I'm pretty sure people like Walt Disney
ice and famous people have had this
right well Disney was rumored to be
frozen but he never was he was actually
buried and in reality there's anything
about 150 people have been frozen by the
alcohol life extension company where
this object comes from and 33 pets the
first person to be frozen was dr. James
Bedard and he was frozen in 1967 he was
an American and professor of psychology
at the University of California is this
an unusual object for the museum to be
collecting I think it's a really
important object the museum to collect
first of all it represents what how a
small group of scientists and members of
society are responding to one of you
know mankind's biggest challenges how to
overcome death but you know really
interesting ethical issues about how we
think about the future so you know are
you you if your brain was put into a
different body how long should a
somebody live for you know what rights
would you have if you were living in the
future if you were revived so you're a
curator would you want to be preserved
like this I think even if medical
science catches up and you could live
with all your personality and memories
I just think ultimately living in the
future will be quite a lonely place with
your friends have family be there and I
just think you know really be a dinosaur
living outside your own time got to
understand that you haven't dissuaded me
through I should live forever hey you
should go for it